[Music]
hi
my name's matt and i'm head of foresight
and insight at the british red cross
cast your mind back to march of 2020
what now feels like several lifetimes
ago
the kovac 19 pandemic was starting to
grip the world and the uk
where i am was entering its first
national lockdown
the british red cross was in the midst
of planning our emergency response
we were gearing up to deliver food
parcels and deliver medicines
support people who were lonely or
socially isolated
and help people who have been moved into
emergency accommodation
but how did we know who needed support
and where we might find them
the day before lockdown began i made our
first
commit to what would become known as the
vulnerability index
my colleague l and i were rapidly
designing a map to model vulnerability
to covet 19
in neighborhoods across the uk this map
would be used to plan
not only the british red cross's
pandemic response
but would also inform other voluntary
and community sector
organizations as well as government and
public health bodies
it needed to be expansive rigorous
and accurate and we needed to build it
quickly
700 commits more than 100 data
indicators and
several new gray hairs later this is
where we are now
my team and i built a set of open source
tools that measured the vulnerability
of different geographical areas of the
uk and their ability to cope
today we have a suite of dashboards maps
and data sets that anyone can use for
free but how did we get there
we had to figure out what makes people
vulnerable
to the disease covert 19
isn't just a public health emergency
it's also
a social and economic emergency and we
needed to account for vulnerability
in a multi-dimensional way
we gathered data on over a hundred
indicators related to people's clinical
vulnerability
and socioeconomic vulnerability as well
as their wider health and well-being
needs
but we had to find some way to merge
everything
into a single vulnerability score and we
needed to do it
fast so i picked up the phone
and i called mike hey i'm mike
a data scientist at the british red
cross after agreeing to redeploy into
matt's team
i took a quick peek at the repositories
he had created excited to see what i
might be working on
my reaction was of course
paddock
what i thought was going to be a project
in its infancy
had already morphed into thousands of
lines of code split across hundreds of
files
data sets repositories add to this the
pressure of a pandemic and the need to
develop rapidly
i wondered what i got myself into
thankfully i was soon to learn that
these feelings of panic were unfounded
the project had a silent hero working in
the background allowing me to quickly
get up to speed
this hero was a tidy verse
so why the tidy verse every data science
problem presents a unique landscape
which must be navigated
here at the british red cross we'd like
to think of the tidy verse as the
cognitive super highway
through many of these landscapes the
signs are clear and easy to follow
and it's easy to show colleagues and
your future self how to navigate back
through the terrain
but this is not to say the tidiverse is
always the correct path to take for
every problem
depending upon the task at hand other
tools and paradigms may be better suited
such as pandas and data table however at
the british red cross we often have a
requirement to develop and collaborate
quickly
and this is where we believe the tiny
verse shines most brightly
it quickly allows us to translate our
ideas to code
this is because the unifying design
principles of the tidy verse
are centered first and foremost around
cognitive performance
not computational performance
to demonstrate why this is important i'm
going to show you some example code
snippets from the vulnerability index
matt introduced earlier for each snippet
i'll demonstrate how the unifying
principles of the televerse
made development quicker and easier
allowing us to respond rapidly to the
emerging pandemic
first let's take a look at the human
centered and inclusive principles
together they acknowledge that data
scientists come in all shapes and sizes
this means the tidiverse apis and
documentation are designed to be read
and written by everyone
irrespective of their background this
means it's not just for computer science
graduates whose idea of a fun weekend
is arguing about whether arrays should
be zero or one indexed
this quote from the televerse design
principles book
sums up the human inclusive principles
nicely
one particularly powerful idea is that
of affordance
the exterior of a tool to suggest how to
use it
for example take a look at this code
snippet written by matt
that calculates a mean total response
time from the fire and rescue
authorities
using a classic deployer style pipeline
without ever having seen the code and on
a little bit of priority based knowledge
it's quick to read and intuitive to
understand what is going on take the
fire and rescue authority stats
filter only for fires in english
dwellings and create a new variable
called
year select only the variables of
interest
and finally group by a geographical
variable to find the average
three year fire and rescue response time
in a given area
the code almost reads like inks pros
listing off a set of clear instructions
there is no requirement to reason about
things that computers are optimized to
do
such as indexing and subsetting the
result is code that is quicker to write
read and collaborate on another
important design principle of the tidy
verse
is that of consistency principally
this idea means finding the smallest
possible set of key ideas
and using them again and again this
manifests itself in two ways in the tidy
verse in data structures and
function apis
the code snippet i'm about to show
demonstrates the power of this idea
effectively
this code generates a data frame of
weights across four domains of
vulnerability
where only two domains should be
weighted at any given time
and the sum of the weights must equal
one
the main power of this snippet lies in
the first function crossing
which generates all combinations of
variables found in the data set while
deduplicating and sorting the inputs
here the yellow arrows demonstrate the
consistent tidy data frame structures
used throughout this example
using one common data structure over and
over again reduced the cognitive load
required to reason about the problem we
were challenged with
one reason for this is that the
consistent data structures mean the apis
of the tidy verse
communicate seamlessly
for example we can see here how the
functions from tidy r
and b player are fit together like lego
blocks this mostly removes the need to
reason about the input and output
structure of the data being passed
throughout the tidy verse
making it quick to learn new tidy
functions and packages
consistency also extends to the naming
of functions throughout the tidy verse
in general tidybs function names offer
imperative verbs over nouns
long names over shortened names and
thematic unity between similar groups of
functions
the end result are functions that are
easier to remember and implement
for this particular code snippet i
recall a deep sense of joy
as i intuitively knew the name of the
functions i needed to recall
despite only using several of them a
handful of times
the final design principle of the tidal
verse is that it should be composable
this means that complex problems should
be solved by combining many smaller
pieces
with each smaller piece easy to reason
about this is realized in the tidy verse
for a predominant
functional programming paradigm that
uses immutable objects
this means problems are solved by
combining functions that transform data
rather than by creating objects whose
state changes over time
we saw the power of this idea previously
where a consistent immutable tidy data
frame object
was used throughout this long code block
demonstrates the idea of composability
nicely but
try not to be drawn and to immediately
understand it instead
notice how many smaller pieces of the
television are used to solve an overall
more complex problem in some instances
some functions such as mutate are used
over and over again the end result is we
are able to solve complex problems
more quickly
in this particular case allowed us to
assess the vulnerability of different
regions of the uk split across different
vulnerabilities of the vulnerability
index
so let's turn back to matt and find out
how these design principles have
impacted our response to the kobit 19
pandemic
have you noticed how all the principles
are linked together
the tidiverse principles are rooted in
cognitive theories of mind
and they make it easy for humans like me
and mike
to build insights out of data sets and
make new tools for people
one example of how we've used our
vulnerability index to design
better services for people is our kovid
19 hardship fund
aviva an insurance company donated 5
million pounds to us to give to people
who are facing economic hardship during
the pandemic
we used our vulnerability index
alongside other research
to figure out that the people most
likely to need financial support
included those without access to state
welfare
older isolated people people facing
homelessness or living in temporary
accommodation
and survivors of gender-based violence
in one region of england this mapping
combined with local intelligence from
our frontline teams
led to more than half of referrals to
our hardship fund
coming from the most vulnerable areas as
of december 2020
we've helped more than 7 000 people with
financial assistance
so following the thai diverse design
principles has made it faster for mike
and i
and others to get our ideas out of our
heads and translated
into something useful in the real world
this cognitive speed is really key for
us
working as a humanitarian organization
to put a spin on the well-known agile
phrase
we need to move fast and save things and
we're not just working with one another
it's often said your most important
collaborator is yourself
six months down the line even if you
don't use the tidy verse itself
we suggest using all four design
principles as inspiration for future
package and code design
writing code and packages in the future
think about cognitive performance
not only computational performance for
our work on the vulnerability index this
meant that there hasn't been a single
time that mike or i
had to explain our code to one another
which is remarkable
we should often be writing code that is
human-centric and designed around how
people actually think and work
the key is to build tools and analyses
faster
for real world impact thank you for
listening
you